[Music]  we've been waiting to tell the story of  natasha romanov for  years it was one of the great post  infinity saga opportunities how to  evolve  into phase four i'm done running from my  past  natasha is a product of all these films  that we've done  you will look at the past again in a new  light and we are sowing the seeds of new  characters into the future of the mcu  it's good to see it too sis  kevin's geniuses that he thinks in this  really huge unexpected way  you know a lot about the characters  already so they're presumptions that you  bring to it  okay you got a plan or shall i just stay  dug and go but my plan was to drive us  away  and we like to subvert those where your  plan sucks  marvel's created something absolutely  extraordinary  we're excited for people to go to  theaters to see and experience this  movie  in its place in the pantheon of the mcu  i made my choice  i'm done running